Henry got bullied at school
this morning.
If we leave right now
and take the
connecting flight
through Paris,
we can be in Kansas
by noon,
and that punk’s house will
be in ashes by 12:30.
No, no.
Best thing you can do with bullies
is ignore them.
Then you sneak into their house at 4 a.m.
which statistically speaking
is the hour people are
least prepared to defend themselves.
Correct.
Once you’re standing
over them
as they sleep in their bed,
you start to beat them
with a thick, heavy, rope
soaked in red paint,
pummeling them over
and over
until they wake
confusing the paint
for their own blood.
When they beg
you to stop,
you laugh
as loud as you can
for as long as
you can
and then
you start to beat
them again.
You know, I may just
hold off on anything
like that
until I connect with
Michelle
and just get the details.
See what actually
happened, you know?
Alright, yeah.
Fair enough.
But thank you.
Oh, yeah.